this episode of fun science is brought
to you by Squarespace let's talk about
music welcome to the world
that was to guess I'd say you probably
liked it but why is that what is it
about music that we enjoy and what
effects does music have on our brain
all that and more in today's episode of
science fun science fun science is the
science of fun yeah now before we talk
about the science of music let's explore
the mathematics behind the musical scale
where did that come from well it turns
out that its origins lying all the way
back in ancient Greece
if you stretch out a piece of string
attach it at two points and pluck it you
hear a note but what happens if we take
another string exactly half the length
and played that one instead it's the
same notes but just one octave higher
this was the simple idea that Pythagoras
discovered back in ancient Greece to
find more notes between these two
Pythagoras divided up the string using
different fractions and it's this idea
that the musical scale of today is based
on so Pythagoras use mathematics to find
intervals between notes that sounded
good but why do some notes sound nice
together while others don't for example
play AC major chord
and it sounds quite nice in music this
is called a consonant sound
however pick a bunch of random notes and
try and play those together as a chord
and
and you get what's known as a dissonant
sound and amazingly it does seem as
though we naturally have a preference
for one sound over the other even for
month old babies were found to prefer
consonant sounds to dissonant ones and
the reason for this well it might
actually be because of the babies
themselves when a baby cries it's
essentially producing one of these rough
dissonant sounds so from a survival
standpoint it makes sense that we find
these sounds to be distressing as it
encourages us to help the infant with
whatever it wants it's also possible
that we don't like these types of sounds
simply because notes that are close
together a harder thought our ears to
separate so it sounds like they're
interfering with each other but what
some of the other effects that music has
on us well to find out fun Sciences
resident musician has prepared a little
song for us
[Music]
getting help the system snake and also
help with exercise she starts the rain
so while it tries a slow down and take a
rest
song song and put your body to the tail
I say come music it help us
music
[Music]
you listen to songs you love you see you
end up driving morosely
music can affect things you this has
been shown with sales of wine a French
music see you fine French wine
outselling one he's really just full of
those fun musical facts isn't he
everyone needs a hobby so while the
particular song that gives you the
chills might not create the same
reaction in your neighbour music seems
to be able to affect us all even in ways
we might not notice and while our
enjoyment of music may not appear to
have any evolutionary benefit our brains
seem to enjoy it nonetheless it's my job
Oh see you next time so maybe you're a
musician and you need a new place to
share your tracks and tour dates with
your audience or perhaps you're just a
fan of music who's looking to build a
following by writing about the alvin's
that you love whatever your next big
move may be it's gonna need its own home
online these days whenever I need to put
together a new website I always go to
Squarespace first as they make it super
easy to get a domain build your page and
keep it up to date all in one place
however while I may sing its praises
please don't take my word for it instead
try it for yourself and start your free
trial today by going to Squarespace com4
slash fun science to get 10% off your
first purchase also if you like fun
science and you want to help us to keep
making it I would love it if you would
consider becoming a patron of the show
just go to patreon.com/scishow see you
next time